[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
compressed sensing and sparsity and I'm
really excited in this lecture to code
this up in MATLAB for kind of a toy
version of an audio signal okay so you
can actually use this idea of compressed
sensing in the real world to reconstruct
audio signals and images even if you
don't have the full the full measurement
resolution even if you don't measure the
full image or the full audio signal and
this is especially useful in sampling
signals in time because there's a really
really important result that you can
actually beat the Nyquist sampling limit
in in practice if the signal that you're
sampling your audio signal that you're
sampling in time or whatever signal
you're sampling at time is sparse in a
Fourier transform basis so this is
really fun when you go to a conference
and you tell people you can beat the the
Nyquist sampling theorem I mean this is
one of the most important results in all
of signal processing for the last
hundred years all of you know digital
communication is kind of built on the
Shannon Nyquist sampling theorem and
information theory and so people are
very skeptical until you break it down
for them so those fundamental limits
kind of that Nyquist sampling limits is
for information dense signal signal
sampling and transmission okay but the
minute that your signal s is the signal
that you're sampling is sparse in some
basis like a Fourier transform or a
wavelet transform basis you can actually
beat Nyquist and you can reconstruct
signals even if you don't sample them at
the at the the kind of the rate that you
would normally need to based on on
Nyquist theorem okay and I'll probably
have another lecture on what the the
Shannon Nyquist sampling theorem
actually is and how it works in signal
processing classically but for now kind
of I'm just gonna walk you through this
example okay our toy example we're going
to cook up an audio signal that
basically has two tones okay so we have
a 97 Hertz and a seven and seven 777
hurt
audio signal and I'm adding those two
cosines together to get this two-tone
audio signal okay and we're gonna this
is gonna be a really small example so I
can run it on my laptop live in this
demo but you could do this on larger
signals if you scale this up to two
bigger computers okay we're gonna have a
4096 sample a high-resolution audio
signal so kind of the truth that we're
gonna compare against is going to have
just over 4,000 measurements okay
and I'm gonna create a kind of evenly
sampled time vector T linspace 0 to 1
with n data points and so that means
that my high-resolution sampling is
going to be basically 4,000 Hertz ok
4096 samples per second but then what
we're gonna do is we're going to pretend
that we only have you know a very few of
those samples spread out not nearly at
that high sampling rate and we're gonna
see can we infer what the original audio
signal was even from massively down
sampled measurements in Y okay so this
should be pretty cool and then I'm just
gonna do some basic computations like
the power spectrum so you can see how
everything looks okay so the original
okay and then what I'm gonna do here I
showed you this randomly sampled signal
I'm only gonna measure a hundred and
twenty eight of those 4096 points and
that's going to be my down sample
measurement Y so this is way below the
Nyquist sampling limit for this 777
Hertz cosine wave normally I would need
to sample much more than 128 samples per
second okay but the catch here is that
these hundred and twenty eight samples
per second are randomly sampled
and I haven't I'm assuming that I have
an extremely precise time stamp of when
they were sampled so I am only
collecting 128 measurements per second
so 128 Hertz on average but I know
exactly where they occurred in time up
to 400 4096 Hertz accuracy up to up to
this resolution in time so I'm gonna let
you think about that
I'll come back to that in a minute okay
so we're going to run this we have
randomly sampled 128 of those
measurements and now I'm just going to
plot kind of what this looks like so
here you can see this is just a zoom in
of a fraction of the second so you can
see it in time of this two-tone signal
so it's got a high frequency at a low
frequency and I think you can see here
these red X's are aware and actually
these are my random sampling points so
you can see that there's some regions
where there's there's very little being
sampled and then there's other regions
where I'm sampling quite a lot and again
because these are the catch is that if
this was uniformly sampled at 128 Hertz
this would absolutely fail I guarantee
it would fail if I uniformly sampled at
120 Hertz but because I am randomly
picking 128 points in time some of them
end up being rather close together so
these are actually pretty close together
points others will be relatively far
apart and you'll get this kind of random
spacing so you'll still be exciting a
lot of frequencies with the sampling
whereas if you uniformly down sample to
128 Hertz you'd basically just alias
anything at higher frequencies so again
this is kind of some intuition for why
we're able to beat the Nyquist sampling
theorem and we'll come back to that and
again in in the frequency domain the
power spectrum you can see that there's
clean two peaks because this is a
two-tone two-tone cosine wave and now
we're actually going to run the
compressed sensing optimization we're
basically going to solve for the minimum
one norm solution s that satisfies my
system of equations okay you know theta
s equals y and in the book in data in
our data book you can find this a data
book you w.com
and there's a link to the PDF in the
comments you can go to this this section
where we actually derive this and figure
out how I define theta and how I define
Y and how are defined s for this
particular problem okay but here I'm
just going to run this optimization and
it might take a little while here we're
using the co samp code
this is a compressed sampling by
matching pursuit that's the compressed
sampling matching pursuit matching
pursuit is basically a greedy algorithm
that allows you to solve this kind of an
optimization very very fast and very
effectively I will probably have a video
on on matching pursuit and greedy
algorithms at some point in the future
okay so I think it's I think it's solved
it actually and now I'm going to add the
compressed sensing results okay so from
that l1 solution s this is the sparse S
vector that was solved for by this
matching pursuit algorithm so this is
the sparse solution to the system of
equations that are consistent with those
128 random measurements in time that I
took up here okay
I get this sparse vector now this
example works because my vector s is
ultra ultra sparse it is too sparse so
that's two nonzero entries at these two
frequencies here so it's really easy to
find a very very sparse solution s that
satisfies that's consistent with those
128 random points in red ok and that's
also why this this cosine runs quickly
and is accurate and gets me the sparse
solution and then when I inverse Fourier
transform that sparse solution I recover
in red this is what I think the solution
is the sparse solution is when I when I
go back to the time domain so even if I
had only these red points but I knew
exactly where they occurred in time and
they were somehow randomly spread out I
would be able to solve for the sparse
Fourier coefficients inverse Fourier
transform and recover my two-tone audio
signal and in a nutshell that's how
compressed sensing works you have these
random measurements these red
measurements many many fewer than you
would traditionally need but because
they're randomly spread out and you know
exactly where they are at exactly what
time you can solve this underdetermined
system for a sparse vector s that's our
sparse power spectrum right there and
then you can inverse Fourier transform
and get the original signal signal X ok
so again you need to have the timing of
your random samples very very precisely
measured you also need to be able to
possibly have two of those measurements
occur right next to each other one delta
T apart one very small delta T apart but
your average sampling rate can be much
much lower if your system is sparse and
if your if your system is sparse in the
Fourier domain and you had this precise
timing of your measurements okay so
that's a really really cool example of
how you can beat the Shannon Nyquist
sampling rate using compressed sensing
if your measurements are random and you
use this this l1 minimization okay
alright thank you